Hello world,
it's Saroj and we're going to dive into
some reality bending research today.
Well, write a program that generates an
image from just the text description.
There's a human condition called
synesthesia where it stimulation of one
cognitive pathway leads to experiences
in a second cognitive pathway.
So a person with synesthesia could be
listening to Beethoven and it would
trigger the taste of sweaty armpit in
their mouth or see the color red when
looking at the number nine the word
literally means joined perception.
Many great artists have this condition
and no doubt it adds to their artistic
ability.
There's something really intriguing about
this idea of being able to express a
thought,
an idea,
a concept in two entirely
different mediums.
Could we replicate this ability
programmatically? Mm, yes.
Generative adversarial networks have
demonstrated that it is possible to create
fake but photo realistic looking
images after training on an image data.
More recently,
a paper called [inaudible] demonstrated
that given any tech sentence,
their model could then create a
photorealistic image out of it.
Think about the implications of that.
This ability to synthesize one data type
to another will eventually allow us to
create all sorts of entertainment with
just detailed descriptions, designers,
engineers and scientists could all
hashed out theoretical concepts with real
time visual feedback on
their thought processes,
but at the same time bad actors could
use this technology to manipulate people
into believing something is real
when in fact it's actually fake.
We'll all need to get smarter to discern
the difference between the two and
indeed several big names are all now
starting to work on ways of merging our
brains with machines,
which would help us do just that.
Think direct thought to media synthesis.
You and I are living in the most
exciting time in human history right now.
So how does stack GAM work?
It consists of two games.
The first one is called stage one.
It takes a sentence as input and outputs
an image with primitive shapes and some
basic colors.
It's a low resolution image like
what a windows phone would capture.
Then the second Gan,
stage two takes that low res image and
original sentence as input and generates
a much higher resolution version of that
image by completing all the details.
A popular task and machine learning is
to learn what's called the density model
of a distribution of some datasets.
So for the density model p of x,
it would accept some input
and say, yes, that's x or no,
that's not x x being the
data we want to model.
Gains have been used to
learn density models.
We want to be able to do
two things with this model.
The first is a sample from it that is
imagined variations of the training data
that we've never shown it before and the
other is to condition on external data
so that we can specify particular
attributes as we sample.
We humans have no problem doing this.
Imagine a pink elephant with wings.
See how fast you did that?
They used a set of images of birds and
flowers with associated text labels as
their training data.
So the task was to build a conditional
density model instead of answering the
question, is this an hex? The question
is instead, is this an ex given a why?
This means we can specify particular
attributes we want in the generated image,
we could ask the generator to generate
a bird with a yellow tail and ask Dee
whether the bird has a yellow tail,
so we'll be able to directly
control the output of g.
The first step is to encode the text
description into an embedded and using a
pretrained coder like word two vec.
No. In our programmatic implementation
we'll see that the only dependencies we'll
need our tensorflow num
Pi and our helper class.
If we move down to the main function,
we can see a high level
overview of what's happening.
We first load up our skip thought model
and store it in the model variable.
Skip thought also called sent two VEC is
the encoder part of an encoder decoder
model that was pre trained on a large
text corpus to reconstruct a piece of text
from it's encoded vector.
So we'll use it to convert our
input text into an embedding.
We can initialize our tensor flow session
and then initialize our models inside
of it.
We'll need to give our model,
the text embeddings the session and
our predefined to batch size as its
parameters.
We want to extract latent variables
from our techs and beddings and we could
just do this directly,
but instead we'll randomly sample
latent variables from a gossipy and
distribution with a mean and a diagonal
covariance matrix are functions of the
text and bedding.
Why?
Because the latent space condition
on tax is usually high dimensional,
like more than a hundred dimensions
and we have a limited dataset waiting
variables generated from it directly
would make it hard for our generator to
learn if we had much more data than
it would make sense, but we don't.
So this step helps us learn from
a smaller Dataset. Minnie mouse.
So
for the generator a d
convolutional network,
the text and bedding is fed into a fully
connected layer to generate the mean
and the values for the diagonal in the
covariance matrix so that we can use them
for the independent
Garcia and distribution.
We'll use these values to compute a
conditioning vector that we can then
concatenate with a noise vector to
generate an image through a series of
upsampling blocks. The discriminator,
a convolutional network,
takes the text and bedding, has input
and compresses it to less dimensions.
Ultimately forming a
three dimensional tensor.
We also feed in the image through a
series of downsampling blocks until it's a
two D 10 cert.
We then concatenate both tensors together
and we use the resulting tensor as
input to a convolutional layer to jointly
learn features across the image and
the text.
Do you ask judge two kinds of inputs,
real images with matching text and
generated images with arbitrary text?
It's got two separate
two sources of error,
unrealistic images for any text and
realistic images of the wrong class that
mismatched the conditioning information.
This could complicate the
learning dynamics, so we
separate the error sources.
In addition to the real and fake
inputs to d. During training,
we add a third type of input,
real images with mismatched texts,
which d has to learn to score as fake.
The discriminators goal is to maximize
the probability that the image condition
on the text is from the
true data distribution and
minimize the probability that
the image is not from the
true data distribution.
The generators job is to
create samples that full d,
it minimizes the probability that
the image is not from the true data
distribution and we use the
popular regularization term,
the Kale divergence to
help avoid overfitting.
So eventually g from the stage one Gan
we'll get really good at generating low
res images.
They aren't very clear and could
contain all sorts of shape distortions.
Some of the details in the text input
could be omitted in this first stage,
so we introduce stage two again that
generates photorealistic high res images.
It conditions on these low res
images and the texts and bedding.
Again to correct any defects from stage
one and extract any previously missed
information in the text to generate
more photo realistic detail for G.
Similar to the previous stage,
we'll use the text and bedding to
generate a lower dimensional golf Sian
conditioning vector, which we then
convert to a three dimensional tensor.
We also input the sample generated
by the first scan through a series of
downsampling blocks until
it's a tutee tensor.
Then we can catenate the image
and text tensors into one tensor.
We then feed that resulting tensor
into several residual blocks to jointly
encode the image and text features.
Lastly,
it's fed through a series of upsampling
blocks that will ultimately generate an
image for d.
It's a similar structure to stage ones
the but with more downsampling blocks.
Since the image size is
a larger in this stage,
once we've got some image texts payers,
we can train our model in the sessions
run function for the number of batches we
defined. We will separately train our
stage to Gan and its own session using the
generated images as input.
Once trained,
we can use the stage to gans generator
to generate some images given a text
input. If we look in our
saved folder after training,
we can view the low res
images that were generated.
We can also view the High Rez generated
images in their respective folder.
As long as you have some images and
some related texts, you can convert.
Pretty much any text into a novel image
using this model. Let's do a recap.
Dan's can be used to learn
a conditional density model.
One great application of
this is converting texts to
images and stack in is an
architecture that can do just that first
converting text to a low res image than
to a high res image. Last week's coding
challenge winner is Mike Mcdermott.
I had some issues in my
video generation code,
which he made a great pull request for
making the dependencies much easier to
install so you can get started generating
videos of your own. Great job, Mike.
It was much needed wizard of the week.
This week's coding challenge is to use
at Gan to convert text to images using an
entirely different datasets. Details
are in the read me get humbling scoping.
The comments and winners will be
announced a week from today and the last
episode of this course, please
subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to create the finale,
so thanks for watching.